von walter dörr mich aufhalten petras
alles war schon wieder so hecker hits
von uns selbst so herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge minecraft heute wir
mal mit einer neuen folge zuschauer
überrascht wie spielen heute
höchstwahrscheinlich krieg sowie games
aber wir schauen erst mal was die
anderen boy zu sagen jetzt grade auf dem
ts sind da haben wir doch hier direkt
mal zwei nehmen da unten sind vielmehr
ok fünfter sind zu viele
das ist zuviel okay dann gehen wir hier
oben hin und zwar zum einen ab meinen
admins auf und ich würde sagen sie doch
mal rein
ja na seid ihr
ich hatte einen anfall habt ihr bock auf
eine runde kriegsjahre games mache es
ist als würdest du regelmäßig eine
person die wie ich ist zeugen
hast du mich verstanden gut
verinnerlicht als oder doch nicht
verlassen
wir gucken und nach einer premium hat
warte mal ich gehe rein
ich komme gleich wieder
hallo leute hat ein erfolg premium
aufkomme religious loca loca loca ich
natürlich entfernt kommet alter ich
pixel ist die schlimmste meppener sie
fix ist die allerschlimmste vom spiele
ich aber genau weil immer das passiert
und locker auf meinem ostwind dem
ausland was nicht mach's nicht alter
schwede
naja ok kein war für mich mehr als die
jazz avantgarde und herbert muss auch
draufgehen bergmann der komplett man
kommt ja getroffen dickmänken kalter und
der läuft rückwärts aus nach warte jetzt
erst mal erst ein bisschen schön
ok ich dir und das gar nicht so schlecht
waren wie ich eigentlich erwartet hätte
auf ein fixes gema pixels gewalt kommt
ich hatte eine halbherzig war etwa so
übertrieben von mir zwar auch zu gehen
so der kommentar
die legen alle hart lane bei mir richtig
liebe ja richtig überlebte doch noch
irgendwann von luca luka du bist ich
hab' ich habe ich habe es an der stimme
erkannt dass du bist jetzt müssen wir
gleich gegeneinander kämpfen luca
ich hole ich hole ihn mir wo ist er froh
dass es in dem glas wenn du alles okay
meist ich zuerst ein bisschen ein
bisschen raus hier
oder kommt nämlich 3par verpackt roche
chips laufen einfach mal rein schießen
luca wir kämpfen weiter ist das
turbulent man pixel sg ist einfach die
von ron walker jetzt gibt es nur noch
nie es gibt noch ein sieg fehlt chichi
ok wack wettkampf gegen wen ich muss ich
muss sagen ich habe noch sechs herzen
oder so aber er kommt keine kämpfe
kämpfe ist einfach verboten aktiviert
ich muss es hacken
hey hallo wo bist du da hinten oder ist
sie verzichtet einfach auch eine diashow
ich bin einfach richtig ausgerastet
einfach nur links linksklick spam und
die maus umgerissen in jede richtung
so wie es sich gehört er aber zu alles
regelt com kenntnis
ja aber ich darf an die teams das
scheiße aber ich erwarte aber trotzdem
spitzen kufa ok alles klar so ein
bisschen baxter muss ja auch sein jetzt
chichi es ist der kleine bruder von
bushido man weiß es nicht
das malta spiel gut gekämpft
ok kommen wir machen es noch eine runde
ja aber warum immer dann ist es nicht im
plan ist immer noch nicht eingebaut in
den fluglehrer mit du musst ein baum ist
und von walter job ich auf hätten
gesperrt krass alles war schon wieder so
hacker wenn du wenn du die wenn du
irgendwie unter dem gegner besser
gereist denn die maus zu hoch dann gibst
du den böse jetzt das sieht dann aus wie
das sieht aus wie hector got a
porter.com georg beckmann so huy nein ja
ich sollte das lieber anziehen
guten hunger haben wir ja alles klar
lebt er noch jetzt nicht mehr
jetzt ist er da und da kommt einer hoch
auf der gefällstrecke und clean up tv
junge ein hit wie böse ja aber warum es
ein bisschen taktik spielen kriegswaisen
gamestar clean up oder geklärt werden
das ist das gesetz ohne da vorne sein
okay okay jetzt mit jason day sommerfest
für die ganze richtung okay gut aber
auch so ist tnt nur mit solchen roten
gold apfel da wohl warum ich verstehe
das nicht hätte springt man meine
mentale wie weg ohne ergänzte wir ringen
ja okay okay und ich sollte doch mal aus
hoffentlich passion ich kenne in der
zwischenzeit okay ist dann kann mich
gerne überraschen gut an
nicht mal das equipment ihr mit dem tmt
so und dann nur noch poker janko okay
aber der test sehr gut hatten aber da
wird ein bisschen geschwächt sei nicht
direkt auf den rost gmbh verein direkt
fight
du hast die asse das okay jetzt kann
natürlich weglaufen weil ich da so
schlau meinen text fans auszuschreiben
oh mann das war nicht das war nicht so
klug von mir aus der luft richtig
schnell konnte sein
die fluglinie von einer amerikanischen
internet versorgungsgesellschaft
fachmann da kann die ganze weglaufen das
ist nicht so gut
ok ja ja gut wenn jetzt eh weg läuft ja
kommen dann recht geben daneben aber
laufen
nicht die ganze zeit weg so ok final
death match gegen den brasilianer ich
wusste dass ich wohl schon sagen
wahrscheinlich direkt hinter mir ganz
gut
ja gut ok israel marokko ich hab einfach
50 pfeile ach so das wird ihm wehtun ich
werde sie alle in seiner bürger
reinstecken
aber die fans hat er auch die post bei
mobility sowie ich ja gar keinen fall
ja ok aber jubelte umgebung arbeitet mit
umgebung nice und erst ein okay sie so
wie lange haben jetzt endlich schon
gespielt in den letzten zwei runden ich
weiß ist nicht wahr ist lang 45 minuten
oder länger
ryanair länger wie eine chinesische
fluglinie okay leute ich würde für seine
belassen es dabei
danke an euch mit spielenden pizza
yannick und ich bin geschmeichelt wien
spitzen pizza dankeschön ich okay gut
dann ja dank fürs mitspielen
bis zum nächsten video für euch
zuschauer da draußen haut rein macht es
gut und